rio
jonathan
you made it through to the final round
so far
you've designed and presented a weapon
in your own styles
now we're gonna send you back to your
home forges where you will make one of
the most iconic weapons from history
the viking battle axe
the viking battle axe was a brutal
killing weapon that played a significant
role throughout history
viking warriors were mostly farmers so
when going off the fight they would pick
the tool they had close at hand which
was often a woodcutting axe
when later models took on shapes more
convenient to the fighting man the
battle axe was born the haft was made of
wood and the curved head allowed the axe
to be used to hook an opponent's ankle
throwing him off balance and onto the
ground positioning the viking to go in
for the kill with the large razor sharp
cutting edge the battle axe has a long
and colorful association with fantasy
film and literature being the weapon of
choice for the dwarves and the lord of
the rings and the hobbit as well as for
the players of fantasy computer games
such as world of warcraft good luck
gentlemen
i'm jonathan porter and i am a farrier
the fancy word for a horseshoer as well
as a full-time bladesmith i'm doing a
multiple-layer pattern steel battle-ax
the vikings they used a lot of
multi-layered steel
overall this will be one sturdy axe
i am super pumped about this battle x
the competition is definitely affecting
me i don't know why i don't just come in
here and forge like i always do but this
contest sort of just messes me up man
i just
wasn't paying attention i took my eye
off it and i and i cooked it it's done
i gotta start over unbelievable
i forged another axe head and this time
the blade held together
i think the judges are going to be
impressed with the axe in general
we're buttoned up with a really nice
top-notch handle with leather wraps to
go along with the head that we've worked
so hard for
it's an end result that i think looks
good and i'm proud of so no matter what
they think i'm proud of what i'm gonna
put in front of them this round
my name is ryu lim i was born and raised
in the philippines i'm an iron worker
and i make blades for a living
the studio shop had everything man
i got the bare bones only the the basics
my forge is basically a cast iron pot
with a hole
drilled in the bottom where i attached a
black pipe and on that black pipe i
attached the hair dryer
using the hair
i introduce more oxygen and the more
oxygen you put it the hotter it gets
i'm gonna stretch out the metal and i'm
gonna wrap it around the pipe to make an
eye for the handle
i really have no peak
because it's so big it doesn't fit in my
forge
i had to make some adjustments to remedy
that
when you're working with
high powered power tools you gotta
remember safety first
there were some eye protection
and respirator
the way it's going right now i'm not
getting enough heat
i'm losing a lot of heat very quickly so
i might start over or make a new forge
the first forge wasn't working because
it was too small
so i added a satellite dish around it so
i'll be able to add more coal and make a
bigger fire
it's looking good right now i could move
on to the fun part
what is this there's forging nets
they're viking it the firefighters came
and unfortunately i was delayed
an hour
your biggest thing you got to deal with
is the fact that you're too close to the
vote
i have to move the forge and reposition
everything
hopefully it doesn't affect me too much
towards the end
i don't have electric sauce
i'm gonna have to
carve this down
i spent the last hour
pounding in the handle at the same time
making it
it was tough but i'm just really curious
what the judges are gonna say really a
battle axe doesn't have to be smooth and
shiny it just has to work it doesn't
have to be pretty to split skulls
to test the lethality of your axe i will
strike this side of beef here and see
what kind of damage it does
jonathan you're up first i'm ready
your edge
held it crushed to three bones
it will kill
yes i will
for the next test i'm gonna pass it over
to our european historical weapons
expert
dave
thanks dave
gentlemen the viking axe was designed to
create the maximum amount of carnage on
the battlefield
to test it in a chop test i'm going to
take five blows against this hardened
panel of oak
now oak was the common building material
of the time
and this was the breaching tool of the
time
ready all right
i don't know if i can crawl through that
but it seemed to do the job
that round handle though
boy it wants to twist in your hand
bit of an issue
overall it felt pretty good
ryu you're up next are you ready
i'm ready let's do it
the hand is a little slippery so first
couple of tries it was slipping off i
had to make sure that it didn't go fly
off my hand
you cut about
three and into the fourth bone
this i believe
is a killer
good job thank you very much
dave
my axe may not be pretty
but it can definitely split some skulls
[Music]
well it felt pretty good my hand could
travel on that handle whereas with that
leather wrap
i couldn't really move my hand while i
was swinging
nice job
thank you
well gentlemen your weapons have
performed well thus far but it's not
over yet
we're gonna see just how much punishment
your weapons can take in our strength
test
doug
[Music]
for the strength test your access will
be placed on the specially designed
impact device the arm is set to deliver
maximum force at the point of impact we
will deliver three strikes on the shield
that will give us a good indication of
how much pressure your axe can take
let's see if your weapon will survive
this test
jonathan
let's test it three
two
one engaging
engaging
engaging
i don't see any clear indentations on
your edge
a little indentation of the shield
your half seems to have held
good job thank you
ryu you're next
three
two
one engaging
[Applause]
engaging
that split the shield in half and all
the way through
edge held
half is still secure
good job you have both done yourselves
proud as bladesmiths however in this
competition there can only be one winner
real
you are the forged and fire champion
congratulations
good job buddy good job man
jonathan
your weapon did not make the cut please
surrender your weapon
lee i'm totally proud of the work that
i've done i mean i turned in a laminated
viking battle axe so i'm not i'm not by
any means going home because i didn't do
enough
in this case ryu just did a better job
feel very proud right now i work really
hard for this i guess it paid off it's
stress level got to you in the first
challenge you were able to pull it
together i mean you got a few issues but
you brought a true weapon you should
definitely be proud of thank you sir i
put my soul into forging that axe i gave
it everything i had and now i walk out
as a champion
you